MEGAN SMITH: SO now we're
going to start into the
lightning talks, and
I have the honor of
introducing Susan Wojcicki.
Susan has been at Google since
the start-- she's actually our
first landlord, and I hope
she's going to tell you a
little bit about that.
But Susan is our senior vice
president of advertising, and
she really runs all the products
that make all of the
money that allow us to do all
the amazing things that we're
able to do.
She's an extraordinary
executive, an extraordinary
visionary, a strategic leader.
One of my favorites-- just a
personal story-- my favorite
experiences are--
Susan is always like double
and triple booked, and she
adds a lot of value, so
we get her everywhere.
And often if you're in a meeting
and there's a lot of
people debating ideas, and ideas
are flying around, but
you can't really get moving,
when Susan walks in the room,
it just changes.
Within five minutes, people are
focused on a screen and
kind of narrowing in on where
we're going to go.
She just knows how to lead,
she knows how to see the
future, and she's an
extraordinary leader of Google
and of our industry,
and I welcome Susan
Wojcicki to the stage.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: So good
evening, everyone.
It's really great to see such
a wonderful turnout
for our talk here.
And since this is a developer
conference, I thought I would
talk about a few key principles
that we use when
we're developing Google
products.
And I've been involved for
a long time in a lot of
products, so I summarized
this down to two.
But before I do that, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about my personal story.
And since Megan talked about me
being a landlord, I thought
I would start there.
So when people ask the question,
well how did you
decide to join Google?
I sometimes have to say, well,
my story's kind of unusual,
it's not really like everybody
else's story.
Google actually--
I actually lived with
the company,
Google, for five months.
And I don't think really anyone
else can say that,
except for my husband.
And so what happened was I was
renting rooms in my house, and
so, again, Larry had just
gotten funded for their
company and they were looking
for space, and I was looking
for renters, and we agreed on an
amount, and they moved in.
And at first I didn't really
think that much about it,
other than they were renters.
But then people would read about
it, and then they would
ask me questions.
And I would say, oh yeah, I know
them, they're actually
renting in my garage.
And so I started using the
products, and you have
remember there were a lot of big
competitors out there that
were much, much bigger than this
little company of three
people, at the time.
So I started using the product
and it was pretty good.
And I had this realization at
one moment, because the site
actually went down.
The servers were still running
at Stanford, and it was at
that moment that I couldn't
reach Google, and that's when
I really realized how important
it had become to me
in my life, and I realized the
potential for the world, and
that's when I decided I really
wanted to join Google and be a
part of that future.
So that's my story, in terms
of why I joined Google.
So I joined, and I was there for
one day, and Sergey comes
up to me and says, I have
a mission for us.
It's to organize the world's
information to make it
universally accessible
and useful.
What do you think?
I said, well, I was
in [INAUDIBLE].
So there are less than
20 of us here.
And you guys all just graduated
from college.
So that's a pretty ambitious
goal, right there.
But that brings me to my first
point which is that do
something important, think big,
and have a big goal of
how you can change the world.
And I was really pleased to see
that Larry talked about
that this morning in his
keynote, where he said that
there's so many things that
haven't been done yet, it's
important to focus on the great
things that haven't
happened yet.
And that's really a focus
that we have in
our development process.
And a lot of times, doing
big, ambitious things
sounds really hard.
In fact, they sound crazy, and
they sound impossible.
But when you break them down
into parts, a lot of times you
can realize they're
actually doable.
And doing really hard, crazy
things also has the advantage
that it's a lot less
competitive, because there are
fewer people who want
to do crazy things.
Like you.
So let me give a few stories.
So let me start with
Street View.
So we have the beautiful imagery
that comes from the
Bright Angel Trail in the Grand
Canyon that we have been
working on.
In fact, here in the lobby you
can actually see the camera
that has created it, and you
can actually try on the
backpack, and walk around
and see how we did it.
But when I first heard about
Street View, it was just the
idea, which is let's create a
way to take pictures of all
the streets in the
whole world.
Right?
And I went, OK.
And then, you think about it,
and these ideas sound crazy at
first, but then you start
thinking, how
would you do that?
And you start thinking, well,
you would have cars, and they
would have cameras, or you could
have people, and they
would have cameras, and then you
start talking, well, what
kind of cameras?
And then you find people who
actually really want to do
that, and then you're on your
way to making it happen.
So we just launched our 50th
country with Street View, and
five million miles of
Street View imagery.
So from a very simple idea, we
have something that enables
people to see imagery from
all over the world.
Which is amazing.
So going on to the next big
idea, which we are still
working on, which are
driverless cars.
Now, if you think about
driverless cars, and you hear
about this idea, it also sounds
like this giant idea,
is it really going
to get done?
Are we actually going to
be able to do this?
And if so, when?
And so, there are many,
many benefits.
It's probably the most dangerous
thing we all do, but
yet we have to do it,
which is drive.
And you think about the benefits
of saving lives, and
emissions, and it really
could make a
difference in the world.
So my goal is to have the
people at Google do this
before my kids start driving.
So I have a personal OKR here.
But it's just an example of a
really big idea that doesn't
sound possible that you
can make have happen.
So let me move on to the second
big principle that we
think about.
Now, when I'm working with teams
and they are telling me
they're going to create some new
product, or they have some
idea, and they want to staff it,
and they want to build it,
I ask them, what is
your insight?
Tell me something why you're
doing something new, why
you've observed something in
the world that's different,
and what's your insight that's
going to make this product be
a big success?
And I found that if they can
answer that, the product's
usually a success.
And if they can't, then it's
often time to go back to the
drawing board.
And I think about the insights
as because there's so much
technology, and the world that
we live in is changing so
much, if we go around and we
look really, really carefully
at how the world's changing,
and we see new technology,
sometimes we can see glimpses
of how the world will change
in the future.
And if we can see that glimpse,
then we can build
around it, and we can plan for
it, and we can build those
next generation solutions,
we can build that future.
So I'm going to give a few
examples, actually, of
insights that have been really
important to me and my product
development, and that
have guided me.
And again, a lot of times these
are just one sentence,
but they're powerful because
it's a nugget that you can use
to build your products.
So I was working on
Google Video--
and as you can see, we have
the YouTube logo here--
and when I was working on Google
Video, we were working
with studios who had great
content, and we were working
to bring this online.
But at the same time, after we
had just gotten it online, and
users are starting to be able
to see it, we had this other
video that became very,
very popular.
In fact, it became--
the numbers were significantly
larger than what we were
seeing from the studio in the
studio deal we had done.
And it made me realize
the power of
user-generated content.
So do you guys want
to see that video?
Yes?
All right, let me show you a
few, just 15 seconds of it.
But it was this video that
really gave me that insight
and that inspiration.
What I love about that video is
that the roommate is doing
his homework in the background
the entire
time, and doesn't notice.
But this was an insight.
I realized, wow, this
user-generated content, it can
be really, really powerful.
And today we all know that,
because that's what the world
has become, user-generated
content.
It has its place, it's
very valuable.
There's also all kinds of other
content that's produced
professionally that's really,
really important to the
ecosystem, too.
But it was that video that
really gave me the confidence
in thinking that we should
acquire YouTube.
And I was a big advocate
of it, and
Google spent $1.65 billion.
So sometimes you have one little
insight, and from that
little insight, you make
a really big decision.
So I want to talk about another
insight that's near
and dear to my heart,
which is ads.
I'm responsible for Google's
ads business.
Now, we created an ad system
when Google had not very many
people at the company--
I would say probably like 30
people at the company.
And we didn't really have enough
people even to build a
search engine, let alone to
try to build an ad system
where nobody knew anything about
advertising, nothing.
None of us had ever
worked in it.
But we had an insight, and that
insight is something that
I still use today when
I think about the ad
products that we build.
And the insight's very basic,
but it's ads are information.
Now, if you think about ads
being information, and you
think about them just being
commercial information, then
the ads need to be relevant, and
the ads need to be useful,
the ads need to be shown
to the right person
at the right time.
Just like we think about that
first search result.
And so that meant we had to
build our own ad system.
That meant that if you typed in
flowers, you had to see ads
about flowers.
That if you typed in the name
of any book, all the ads had
to be about the book.
Not just for a bookstore, but
for that actual book.
And so that's a principle that
we use that caused us to build
an ad system.
And if I think about things
today, sometimes I'll get
questions, like when we first
went into display, people
would ask me how do you
feel about image ads?
How do you feel about
video ads?
Do you think an image ad
could not be a good ad?
You think about that.
Well, an image is information.
Are images useful to you?
Yes, then an image ad can be
useful provided it's served at
the right ad, at the right
time, to the right user.
All of it, at the end of the
day, is about serving right ad
and making it useful.
So that's an insight that
we've used across our ad
business, from beginning
till present.
And just going forward, moving
really quickly to the present,
if you look at today, and you
say, well, what do you see
about today?
What are things that
you're focused on?
I would say, we have
to be thinking a
lot more about location.
We have all these phones, the
phones know where we are, how
do we make all the services
that we have
super relevant to us?
So you think about all of you
having traveled, probably come
from all different places, and
staying in hotels, and looking
for places to eat.
Now, how many of you have
actually gotten some kind of
offer related to where you
are right now that would
be useful to you?
I'm looking, but I
see a few people.
They are the brave souls who--
or the people who have special
technology, or
have special insights.
But it's something that doesn't
really happen yet, but
there's no reason it shouldn't
and couldn't.
We should all be getting useful
information based on
where we are right now.
And the reason we haven't, is
just because those systems
haven't been built out yet.
This so it's just an example
of an insight in the way we
should think about things
in the future.
So just to sum up, those are my
two insights, that's how we
think about building.
We think about doing things are
really important, things
that haven't been done yet,
things that will be used by
billions of people, and to think
about insights, and what
the future will look like.
Get an insight into that future,
and then build for
that future.
And by building for it, that
will become the future.
So I'm very excited about the
future of technology and how
it's changing our world.
I think there are so many
opportunities for us and for
all of you, and I'm looking
forward to that future.